Alright, so
We're going on holiday this week to Lisbon
And you bros are coming along. Let's go
Wow, it's so nice here and the weather is amazing
I'm so glad we went. And everyone is looking at me.
He thinks I'm filming him
Alright alright alright
We just arrived at the hotel
Can I hold it with my shoes?
Vlogging with my feet is not a good idea. Ahhh!
We're gonna go out. Explore soon. Hopefully it won't rain
But it should be fuuuuuuuuuuu
*amazing roll*
Let's go
This guy is having a bad day
Someone just tried sell me hash
He's like: "You from Sweden? You don't like hash in Sweden?"
No, in Sweden we don't like it. Everywhere else is fine.
Well, I'm really glad we're skipping
the UK weather, for all this
Thanks
Thanks Lisbon.
Hey, what if we go on one of those?
Marzia: Let's do it
This road, man.
Oh my God
Okay, so now we're at the Oceanarium, which is really famous here in Lisbon.
There is one fish that I really wanna see.
What is the fish called?
Marzia: The sunfish
The sunfish
Lets spot some sun-
Look at this
I think I see it
Oh my God, there it is. Oh my God, what is that thing?
Oh my God
What the hell happened there?
*laughs*
Bruh oh my God
What is that fish?
I can't. It's so ugly. Oh my God
I won't lie. This is definitely me if I was a fish
Marzia: Thought you were talking to me at first *Pewdiepie laughs*
Oh no. Not closer plea- *Pewdiepie laughs*
Oh my God. No.
Please
*Sound of waterfall*
Look at this
They're so cute!
What is he doing?
I wonder where all the fishes are. I can't see any of them
There can't be any fishes here
*whale mating sound*
Marzia: We're going back. It's so cold
Nice weather
It's like rain and sun at the same time
Uhhh...We're going back to the hotel
This is just too crazy
Can't handle it
What are you doing?
Marzia: It's so cold
They're trying so hard to sell drugs here. it's so crazy.
Marzia: Where's the hotel?
We're there.
Marzia: Where?
I told you. We don't live here
*Marzia laughs* You would...you would be so lost without me. Seriously
My hair is the best ever
Marzia: Good morning
I look like I'm from Dawson's Creek.
Good morning
We're going for breakfast
And then we're going out in the rain again cause it's still raining
But I..I really need to do my hair *Pewdiepie laughs*
So...
Didn't fix my hair..
But I wanted to talk about something
The car video that we did
Is pretty much going viral
Ummm..
Did I..No, I did not like my own video *Pewdiepie laughs*
Uh...Which is awesome!
I don't think I had a viral video in...
*dramatic pause*
Forever
I feel like
I'm finally figuring out
What I'm doing on youtube
Which is really cool
We're here at some old castle
Very exciting
But
Look at this
The view is not bad
Oh my God. It's so windy
Ughh
I feel like we're in San Francisco
It's so weird
Nice position bruh
*Marzia laughs*
Marzia: Come on
Oh my God
*Pewdiepie thinking "Dat Booty Tho"*
*Pewdiepie is just being himself*
*Peacock screams*
Oh my God
*Peacock screams again*
Calm down
Aerobics
*Pewdiepie laughs* My legs
*Inaudible singing* *Marzia doing her awesome dance moves*
Marzia: Do you like this action?
*Marzia laughs*
So our Lisbon trip...
Didn't really work out as planned
It's pouring down
Oh God
And it's gonna pour down all day
But it's okay
We're going for lunch
Hopefully...
We won't be soaked by- *Pewdiepie laughs*
I can't talk
It's raining
That's what I'm trying to say
The weather is nicer
We're in another city now
And
On top of a mountain
And this place is just insane
It's so cool
It's like straight out of a fairytale
I love it
We're so high up
Like we're almost by the clouds
I'll show you the view in a second
But it's amazing
Let's make six hundred tiles of the same thing
Yes
Ooooh mah Gawd
Let's go in
Woah
Holy shit
That fucking view man
Jesus
I feel like I'm playing Uncharted right now
*Marzia give Pewdiepie a kiss on the cheek <3*
Awww
That view man
Marzia: It's beautiful
So pretty
Marzia, oh my God
Marzia: What?
I have amazing 3G connection here
Alright, castle number 2
It's crazy
So..
This is the same region
Uhh...
It's amazing
I'm blown away
Are you finding anything interesting?
*Pewdiepie shoves Marzia and fakes a soft scream*
*Pewdiepie laughs*
There's a kangaroo?
Where?
Marzia: You see it? There
Oh, there is the Kanga- Oh my God, you're right!
*Pewdiepie laughs*
Okay so..
That's the castle we just visited.
Now we're gonna go to a well
I don't know what that means but Marzia keeps talking about it so I assume that it's cool
It better be...
Drag me all this way
That's super creepy..
Oh my God.
What the hell?
Ehghgh. *Sound of Pewdiepie being uncomfortable with this situation*
Oh, it's dripping everywhere.
Oh my God..
Oh my God, there's water everywhere
Whoa.
What is this?
Oh my God
Scare Pewdiepie,
Season 2.
*Pewdiepie laughs* What the fuck...
*Grunts*
Woah *Pewdiepie laughs* it's so wet
Oh my God, this is terrifying
We're the only ones here
*inaudible Marzia dialogue*
Okay let's go here
follow me
Marzia: But I have a hat...
*Pewdiepie laughs*
Nice hat bruh
Marzia: Thank you
Okay, let's go
What if we get lost?
Marzia: Umm..It's very dark here
It gets better here
Ahhh *Sound of Pewdiepie wondering about the situation* Marzia in the background: *laughs* how does it get better?
Oh my God, this is so creepy *Pewdiepie is creeped out*
What is this?
Oh my God, I'm seeing ghosts
*Marzia says wow in the background sounding amazed* I am seeing ghosts through the ca-, I just saw..
And Pewdiepie and Marzia were never seen again
Oh..Dead end
If my battery runs out, I am literally dead
What the fuck is this?
Where am I going? *Pewdiepie is REALLY creeped out*
Oh, it goes up
*Pewdiepie exhales breath*
That was scary
*Pewdiepie laughs* That was legit scary
I made it! *Pewdiepie is relieved*
I made it!
*Sound of waterfall*
Oh my God
I wanna jump from there
*Marzia says "Wait" in the background*
I'm legit blown away by this place
It's so fucking cool
Marzia in the background: Get out of my shot man. Pewdiepie: It's like littl-, it's like little mazes and shit everywhere
We're going now here
To go to the other place underground
Are you ready for this?
Marzia: Yeah
Okay...
Made it alive?
Lady in the background: Yeah
*Pewdiepie laugh*
*Marzia laughs*
Oh my God *Pewdiepie is amazed*
Marzia: We made it! Pewdiepie: Woah
Marzia: Move!
Holy shit
This is like..
Shadow the Colossus *Video game reference*
Oh my God
Ahh! God, you pushed me. And you scare me so much
Marzia: I'm sorry
Don't freaking push-, oh my God
This is so amazing
I don't believe it
Alright
Are we going down?
Marzia: Yes
Pewdiepie: Look how much water there is
Ahh..Okay. We're down in the well
Oh wow, that is awesome
That is so cool
*Pewdiepie imitating "da da da" sound effects repeatedly*
We're done exploring for today
I got this beer *Pewdiepie laughs*
*Grunts*  *Marzia moves Pewdiepie over to get in the bed* Oh..ow..what are you doing
Okay, well..this is the Lisbon vlog..
Thanks you for coming along. Today was a really fun day
Marzia: Yes
Sintra was awesome
if you go to Lisbon, definitely check out Sintra
Cause..
*Marzia corrects Pewdiepie's pronunciation of Sintra* Pewdiepie: it was awesome
Thank you for watching. Leave a like if you enjoyed. If you want more vlogs, let me know and...
*Pewdiepie distracted by Marzia brofist*  Pewdiepie: What are you doin- *Pewdiepie laughs*
*Marzia mocking Pewdiepie's outro* Marzia: As always.. *Marzia makes Pewdiepie kiss her fist* Marzia: Stay Awesome!
*Pewdiepie tries to do the outro himself* Pewdiepie: As always.. *Pewdiepie laughs* ..brofist